- Live TV means you can't plan
for what's about to happen.
And sometimes there's some
serious medical surprises.
Let's watch it together.
Be whoop.
- [Announcer] It looks
like Ruben is in the lead
and here it goes.
- Oh, wipe out.
Whoa!
That could be a knee injury,
an ankle injury and a head
injury and a broken rib
all in one.
- Riverside Park, Rob Black, Global News.
- Great sign off, though.
The fall was so bad it reminds me
of Johnny Knoxville's thing with the bull.
- It's time for our How you
Doing Halloween Costume Contest.
We do it every year.
It's always a lot of fun.
Let's get started.
Our first (indistinct).
- Oh, oh!
(woman gasping)
- Oh!
- [Announcer] The show cut to black
and went to an extra
long commercial break.
But when it did come back
on, Wendy was back up.
- That was not a stunt.
I'm overheated in my
costume and I did pass out,
but, you know what?
I'm a champ and I'm back.
- Get evaluated.
Overheating is a real issue.
Dehydrating is a real issue.
Heat stroke is a real
issue and it shouldn't be,
oh, I just had a heat stroke, I fainted,
I'm good to go now.
That's not how it works.
Okay.
A little dancing, a little dancing!
My dance moves are just as good as this.
(dance music)
- Yeah.
- What can go wrong medically here?
- You okay?
- Think someone got hurt.
- [Dancer] My knee, my knee snapped.
- Usually when patients
describe a knee snapping
they mean the knee gave out.
Most commonly this can happen
with a meniscus or an ACL.
Sometimes a PCL injury
if there's some kind
of weird collision that happened.
- I didn't fall.
- I was catching her weight.
- Oh, I see what happened.
Okay.
So there's potential for
a meniscus injury there
as well as an MCL injury.
At that moment, if you have
a tear of that ligament
you're just gonna get so
much swelling and bruising.
He's gonna get an x-ray
to make sure that no bones are broken.
He's gonna get some crutches.
He's gonna get follow up, get an MRI.
Find out that the medial
meniscus and the MCL are torn.
Potentially either do
rehab and/or surgery.
And will be back on his feet
dancing his little heart away.
(tense music)
- The problem is...
(woman crashing)
- Oh!
I did not expect a face
first plummet like that.
Call for help.
First thing that we do, call for help
before even investigating.
And the microphone's still in her hand.
The first thing you want
to know is making sure
that the person is conscious.
Are they breathing?
Do they have a pulse?
Remember if there's no
pulse, you call 9-1-1
and you start those chest compressions,
chest compressions chest compressions.
But it looks like she's kind of with it.
So my prediction here and
suspicion, is that she had
something known as a
vasovagal syncopal episode,
where, because of nerves,
because of extreme tension
her blood vessels dilated,
her heart rate dropped,
and as a result she wasn't
bringing enough circulation
to her brain.
And she collapsed.
This is very dangerous,
not because of the actual
situation that's happening
with the low blood pressure.
But the fall, the fall
is the dangerous part.
She fell face first.
- [EMT] So Karen, can you hear me?
- As an EMT, you're really in a bad spot
because you have no
idea what just happened.
The person isn't talking.
You're trying to get information.
You don't know,
does this person have
underlying medical conditions?
So for their role,
the most important thing
is stabilizing the patient
getting them to an area
where they can receive adequate care.
(siren blaring)
She was treated for
dehydration and released
from the hospital.
She will return for the showstopper round.
Okay, so dehydration can
precipitate a vasovagal episode
but it could also cause a
fainting episode all on its own.
Because what happens is
if you're dehydrated,
meaning you haven't
consumed enough beverages,
you don't have water content.
You actually lose a little
bit of blood volume.
And when that happens
you can't generate enough pressure
to bring the oxygenated blood
to where it needs to go,
like the brain and the vital organs,
especially when you're standing.
And as a result, with
this blood pressure drop,
you actually just faint
as a lifesaving mechanism.
Your brain wants you to go flat
because when you're flat,
the lower blood pressure
can still circulate
the oxygenated blood throughout your body.
Correcting dehydration
in a severely dehydrated
individual is also very important
and needs to be done carefully.
'Cause if you rehydrate too quickly
with the incorrect type of fluids,
you can actually cause
swelling in the brain
and cause a patient to die that way.
There's a lot of things
that need to be taken
into account here.
(piano playing)
- Ooh, she looks stressed.
- [Panelist] She okay?
- [2nd Panelist] You okay?
(people talking excitedly)
- Is she gonna throw up?
- Okay?
- Again, very difficult to
figure out what's going on.
I like this position.
It makes it easier for
the blood to return back
to the heart and go up to the brain.
- Makayla has condition
that's pretty rare.
- In seventh grade, I was
diagnosed with Vasovagal Syncope.
- That is not a rare condition.
Now maybe in individuals
who it happens to quite
often is a rare condition.
There's two mechanisms at play
during this type of syncope.
One is increased
parasympathetic nerve output,
meaning that we're increasing
that rest-digest mechanism
nervous system in your body
that opens up blood vessels,
which is good when you're
lying down and relaxed.
Not good when you're trying
to perform physically
on stage because it
drops your blood pressure
therefore not bringing
oxygenated blood to the brain.
And then at the same time it shuts down
sympathetic nerve firing.
So think about this, the blood
vessels in your legs expand.
So blood pressure drops.
Now, if your heart was allowed
to sympathetically respond
it would increase its cardiac output
by beating faster.
As a result, you would be okay.
You wouldn't even feel
that something's going on.
But because you're shutting
down the sympathetic
and overdriving the parasympathetic
you're creating a really bad dis-imbalance
that causes someone to faint
and potentially really hurt themselves.
- Well, a very, very heavy,
heavy rotation tonight.
We had a very dare darison bite.
Let's go hit terace tazen
is in pavet that hamen pet.
- Do we know what happened here?
Look like potential stroke.
- [Man Offscreen] She
claims it was a migraine.
- There are types of
migraines that could present
with neurologic symptoms
known as complex migraines.
I would want a full workup
to see if there was in fact a stroke.
Now in young, otherwise healthy people
sometimes the cause of
a stroke could happen
as a result of a PFO
that generally people don't
know about that they have.
But as a result,
if you ever have a blood clot in your leg
and it starts traveling to your heart
it can transfer, instead
of going into your lungs,
into the left side of your
heart, through that hole.
And then as a result gets shot up
to the brain leading to a stroke.
- This is me 10 years ago.
- Dan Harris
I've read this book where he
talks about this very moment.
- Researchers report people who take
cholesterol-lowering drugs called statins
for at least five years
may also lower their risk for cancer,
but it's too early to prescribe statins
slowly for cancer production.
- [Dan Offscreen] At this
point, I realize I'm helpless.
So I bail right in the middle.
- Back to you.
- [Announcer] We're gonna go
back now to Robin and Charlie.
- [Dan Offscreen] I knew
with rock solid certainty
that I had just had a panic
attack on national television.
- Panic attacks are a real phenomenon.
And people think that
they're all in their heads.
Panic attacks may start in the mind,
but they continue out to
the rest of your body,
which means that you feel
like your heart is racing
a million miles an hour.
You can't take a deep breath.
There's an impending feeling of doom.
You feel weak, you feel
numbness, tingling.
That's why so many people will describe it
as a near heart attack episode.
And sometimes we do wanna
rule out a heart attack.
- To spend years in war zones
where I covered the heroics
of our men and women overseas
and got a real taste of both
the horror and the adrenaline
of combat after years of
always barreling forward.
When I finally slowed down,
it was as if my mind
revolted and I got depressed.
And so in my free time,
I briefly, but stupidly
began self-medicating
and it was those recreational drugs,
my doctor would later tell me,
that almost certainly produced
the on-air panic attack.
- I wouldn't say it's
necessarily those drugs
that caused it.
It could have indirectly caused it
by increasing the feelings of anxiety
because a lot of people
will take feel good drugs
when they're depressed.
And as a result, those
feel good drugs will mess
with your neurotransmitters
leading to higher highs
but also lower lows.
And as a result, withdrawal symptoms
that can make it feel like
you're having a panic attack
or make it feel much worse.
So much so that it could disrupt
you in your place of work.
I do recommend you read
Dan Harris's "10% Happier".
Check it out on Audible, my partner.
- Stuff went wrong
during my own live event.
My tour, my Alive Tour,
click here to check out
everything that went wrong.
As always, stay happy and
sorry for the haircut.